i've been going to the gym i joined this
gym and um
it's a uh jewish orthodox gym in
brooklyn
and uh it's really very packed
five thousand people lifting one cat
pulling the head of a chicken off
new york you know it'll bounce back guys
it's going to bounce back
yeah so no no honestly i don't but i
would say that
i gotta stay here i don't know why you
young guys are still here but uh i mean
honestly it's
uh it seems like uh you know it's a
different new york now
you know it's a lot of um it's a lot of
scootering around for no reason
it's a lot of uh you know i don't know
people are uh
still driving around tonight it's kind
of like being in high school you know
everything closes early you got no money
you know you're walking around there's
nothing going on fights break out for no
reason i don't know what's happening but
uh
yeah i guess once the cold really hits
because it's feeling it now that like
it'll be a different level of uh of uh i
guess sad
out there but um you know what what am i
gonna say you know
if you were like where would you be
before this
if you were us dave where would you go
wuhan china
bring it back to the stores
yeah let's kill the head vampire
[Laughter]
will you ever be able to collect bats
again i don't know
i have all these bat leftovers in my
fish
can a man have a few pet bats laying
around the house
now have you thought of moving at all
like i know you you you love new york
how do you just bought your play have
you thought of like [ __ ] me i would
actually move somewhere else
i'd have to bring my mother with me you
know and uh right you know it's funny
with her and i we don't zoom
i just scream into her ring camera
did she eat something
no i gotta stay here because of her i'm
the primary
care me and my sister so i gotta be in
this area she's on the island and uh
you know we were really in the zone
there for a while this is kind of a good
uh coveted story there because uh you
know she got the antibodies
and uh we were like whoa excellent we
could take her out now
so i took her out to a restaurant and it
was like you know that moment like where
they're like allowed to eat back inside
and i was like should we do it should we
not do it is it safe
so he was sitting outside the restaurant
and then um
a swarm of bees attacked us and she's
definitely allergic to bees so i was
like we better get inside and just
roll the dice here because you know the
beast thing you know you're not even
gonna get in the hospital they won't let
you in the parking lot with that now
so you know that's what we had to do but
yeah it's very it's very difficult for
the um
you got a lot of first responders out
there they i don't know what these
people go into
it's horrible so um i would say for you
young guys
i don't know i mean like going on the
road there really is not much road out
there and whatever is out there you know
is it safe is it not safe
we're all rolling with that but you know
you still want to go out there and
and and perform so you know it's really
tough i really uh
i really i really uh don't know what to
say like you know there is no good
place right now but um new york
definitely is so different
it really is like it really is like kind
of
my joke was like you know if you ever
wonder what it was like to live in
rochester
[Laughter]
what kind of mask are you guys rocking
out there oh i i don't know
i have that uh blue one that yeah
that grey's anatomy yeah brendan has
been using
brendan has been using the same
temporary mask since march
i've literally just been walking around
with my hand covering my mouth
that was that guy
guys if you want to see david tell
live and in the flesh probably a little
bit you know socially distant but still
yeah right in front of your face uh he's
going to be at the celebrity theater
in atlantic city this saturday uh go
check him out you know there's not that
much going on right now so the fact that
you can see a live david tell show
is very very good news the celebrity
theater in atlantic city
this saturday and uh it's always good uh
talking to you dave
yeah you know thanks for having me guys
uh you know uh
all i'm gonna say to the uh to the fans
and everything is that um
i missed you guys and i hope i really uh
i hope uh
the new year does bring you know a
chance where we can do these shows again
and um jim and uh sam thanks for having
me on
it really uh you know it really uh
cheered me up and that's what it looks
like